what's up everyone we are back with
Naveen Jane we are going to be talking
about meta transcriptomics chronic
diseases how illness is optional so tell
us about that and you were discussing
that technology finally exists now for
us to be able to understand what is
going on inside your gut
until mater transcriptomics we could
never figure out what actually is being
done inside our gut all we could do was
find out what organisms may possibly
exist most companies were doing
microbiome testing are in fact using
such ancient technology that in that
essentially doesn't tell you much so
most of the companies when you go out
and get the microbiome test done they
use something called 16s sequencing so
if you're using you go to anyone's
website the minute you hear the word 16s
run away that's a scam right but most
people have been that's all they do 99%
of the companies that today they do the
microbiome sequencing use 16s so that's
it complete waste of money run away so
companies like you biome American gut
project you know companies like biome
all of these guys are just completely
scamming people like you and tells just
what is 16 s 16 s is a fraction of a
gene that only exists in the bacteria so
by definition you cannot see any viruses
which are phages Wireless says RNA
viruses East fungus mold you can't see
any one of this stuff right and then the
16s is also has a small variable portion
that can show you what genus this
bacteria comes from not the species not
not strain what genus at a genus level
every one every human being has the same
Genesis it's like saying the genus of
India is there are some man there are
some women there are some young people
there's some old people same as America
and some people say oh but this genus is
hot this is higher than that but there
are more women in India than they are in
America
and so this is really where they'll come
down to say hey there are more women in
India than they are in America and there
are more crimes in India so women are
criminal and that's really all they we
could do there's a prophet ala is too
high and they are sick so must provide
Allah is really the bad one right or the
Firmicutes are too high or better
oddities are too high and somehow that's
why you're sick at that level everyone
has the same Genesis so there's nothing
you can get out of it right then so you
can't see any species you can't see any
strain or worse you don't even know what
is being done are these guys producing
this stuff that's good are they
producing this stuff that's bad and
within the each Jeana said you can
imagine it could be a man but man could
be Paul it could be Ellen it could be
John even then it doesn't tell you that
then he said well it could be a plumb
bar it could be an electrician it could
be an entrepreneur now you say oh I see
that but the main thing is even though
the Paul may be an entrepreneur that
simply tells you what is he capable of
doing it doesn't even tell you what it's
doing and that's where the real
advantage comes in is when someone can
say he is working on producing things AI
and is this good or bad is he's working
on building carpentry coventry now is it
good or bad right so my point is what
really comes down here is what is being
done and that's called functional
microbiome and there is no company on
earth other than one company called Y
ohm that does that period this
functional microbial so the normal 16s
sequencing is doing it from a oh you
have this many men in this many women
these many old people this many young
people and that doesn't give you what
that young person is doing at that
moment in the ecosystem you don't even
know in that young person is it Paul
Allen or John is it an entrepreneur or
versus a plumber or electrician and then
even though is an electrician what
actually is doing yeah
right yes same type of things now the
other technology called metagenomics
matter genomics is really called DNA
sequencing and it DNA sequencing level
you can see all the organisms but the
problem again is you can see every
organism so it is substantially better
than 16 ass
but you still can't figure out what they
are doing you can see what they are
capable of doing and the same person may
be capable of doing 10 different things
right so what we see as by looking at
the functional microbiome or matter
transcriptomics which is called RNA
sequencing RNA the good thing about RNA
is you only see the organisms that are
alive you don't see that that is tough
so when you do the DNA sequencing matter
genomics anytime you eat any food it has
a DNA so you get plant DNA and you get
the meat DNA and when you look at the
microbiome you see so much of false
positive because you see whole bunch of
stuff that's coming through and it's all
dead so you don't see any you see a
whole bunch of dead stuff and you've no
idea are they actually in your gut or
they're simply passing through and in
the meta transcript is the RNA
sequencing it was what enables you to
see the alive yes so RNA as you can see
is really replication of DNA that means
you only see RNA when things are
replicating in a large and they align
because it's a short cycle that means if
it's not alive is going to be dead
there's no no RNA being produced anymore
it's not replicated right and by looking
at the transcripts it shows you exactly
what is being released right so think
about it the ten different organisms
could produce exactly the same thing so
if you're simply looking at the organism
level you can say what Alan has
completely different set of organism
then Paul does but both have diabetes so
diabetes can't have anything to do with
the organism because both are different
however what they don't see at that
level until you have matter
transcriptomics you say oh my god both
of them are producing LPS and that LPS
is causing inflammation that's causing
the insulin resistance and that's the
reason there
both diabetes diabetic which is because
organisms may be different but they're
producing the same things also the same
organism can produce multiple different
things that means the same Paul one day
could be building a chair and next day
he's fixing the fan right because Matt
they're capable of doing multiple things
depending on what incentive they have
they got paid to build a chair is arm up
with the chair next they say hey can you
come and maybe they'll work food we
brought into our ecosystem what is
happening with our and you are very
bright I mean so and what happens is
think of our gut microbiome as a
computer so information processing unit
and food is the information when we
change the information it changes what
comes out interestingly the microbiome
since they live in very close proximity
there's something and now the science is
star scientists are starting to discuss
is what they call the horizontal gene
transfer or the gene shedding that means
the algorithms are starting to share
their genes that means I can now if I am
only eating one type of food and there
are certain organisms that can digest
the food and others are not getting fed
they start to share the gene that can
actually start to digest and they both
can start to not do the same thing yeah
right this is very interesting is there
this gene transfer that happens or a lot
of the times to survive they see in this
environment for Alan I'm just not
getting this food so they start shedding
the genes that are capable of digesting
the food is it we don't need it it's
never coming Yeah right
so people who eat who are vegetarian
they start shedding genes that actually
in their microbiome digest meat and
that's why when they do eat me tell me
why they get sick they get sick right
interestingly what also we found is that
we are able to in
fact not only understand what they're
doing but we find the people who are
different are able to process the things
very differently so what I'm trying to
say is we see the people who are
vegetarian we see in their gut
microbiome they are able to take
carbohydrate and turn them into branch
chain amino acid which is the precursor
to protein so that your gut microbiome
can convert carbohydrates into protein
that is not something people I would
have ever thought right our microbiome
our detoxifier in a sense if you live in
an area where there is lot of toxin like
for example or you eat food that have
certain amount certain toxins like MSG
the people who eat a lot of MSG their
gut microbiome evolves to take the MSG
and detoxify it into some completely
benign and they're totally fine you and
I eat msg we don't have those microbiome
and we get headache mm-hmm the point is
it is our gut microbiome that is
essentially constantly changing and
evolving and adapting as we are adapting
our diets and this illness is optional
mentality is that I I go through the
process of volume and understanding my
meta transcriptomics then I get this
sort of dynamic understanding of what's
going on in my microbiome and then as
I've been using volume I've been able to
at the grocery store and that's out
let's do cuz this segment just on the
technology and then I'll come back about
all chronic diseases happen and how do
you prevent them and how do you make a
less optional right so in this one I
just wanted to focus on what are the
technologies that allow us to analyze
what's happening inside the gut and yeah
so understanding the functional
microbiome is the key and there's only
one company on the planet that does that
today's company called wild VI ome and
we essentially are able to look at every
single thing what your gut organisms are
doing not what they are capable of doing
or what they could have done what
they're actually doing and that is the
key because you want
how far more about how yeah okay so how
we do that is we are able to take a
small small amount of your poop able to
do a complete RNA sequencing that RNA
sequencing tells us all the different
transcripts of different organisms and
then we put them in a different pathways
and say oh how much of butyrate which is
really really good nutrient for the body
it's a short chain fatty acid it really
fits in your gut lining it really you
know improves the lots of conditions in
the body it's a good nutrient uterine
butyrate and we see how much of that is
being produced or how much of things
that are really harmful to you such as
Lippo polysaccharide LPS if you're
producing a lot of LPS and not producing
enough butyrate you guaranteed that
you're gonna have lot of inflammation in
your body and in is this fairly even
though our microbiomes are about 95
percent different is this pretty similar
is you want low LPS and you want high
butor yes yes that's similar that is
similar so LPS is a compound that's very
inflammatory and when you have lot of
inflammation in your gut it is going to
bound to do not only have the gut lining
starts to become permeable and you get
leaky guts and then also the LPS when it
goes in your body it causes the immune
system to react so heavily and the first
thing the immune system does is causes
inflammation in fact LPS is so deadly if
you were to take a pure 90% LPS and if
you are exposed to it you'll be dead in
30 seconds oh right it is very highly
inflammatory compound right so so max so
going back to it the way to analyze
microbiome used to be culture and the
culture could only look at the Marquee
organism that grow in oxygen that means
all of the anaerobic which is I would
say majority of organisms in our gut are
anaerobic we never saw them then came
about the 16s and that is the complete
as we discussed it just really really
doesn't do much matter genomics is
better than 16s but it only tells
to potentially what can happen and you
get a lot of false positive on all the
dead stuff that actually is not in your
gut and the most advanced technology
really is the matter transcriptomics
that's looking at your RNA only looks at
this stuff that is a lie but more
importantly is doing the functional
aspect of what is actually being
produced because what matters to the
human body is what is being produced not
what could have been produced yep
that's good that's really important
understanding of meta transcriptomics
and what I was doing okay